non consigli e dormire sì che pensano
due nutra ball criteri a luigi vinci e
poi gettata se stories che ho visto
perché il luca sue creature screw ace
morsa parisi mentis non parli immagina
così di scarto misterioso passerà in
cassa se storia assurda the years at
epoca koolance brasile bella a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovo video
io sono quali j
oggi siamo su un videogame che mi avete
richiesto ma non so neanche a
specificare quante mail mi sono arrivate
siamo su pesate lo me l'avete richiesto
nell'ultima settimana
allora i premiati sono tornato da praga
mi son trovato una sfilza di mail che mi
chiedeva di giocare a questo è meno
chiedevate già la prima a che bello
questo il menù che bello la vivace
insomma e vabbè allora l'unico problema
di questo videogame è un invio horror
che esiste soltanto in lingua brasiliana
c'è parlamento non c'è in inglese e
quindi in praticamente penso che non
capire un cazzo ma comunque va beh
infatti per questo non lo volevo giocare
ma data la valanga di mail continue che
continuano ancora adesso ad arrivarmi
doveva assolutamente farlo quindi direi
di iniziare entrar questo l'ho capito eh
va beh sì c'è una porta fantastica
benissimo
grazie mille senza le braccia proprio
aperta col pensiero va bè andar foulard
interagiscono oggetto wow è prosar gioco
va bene dovrei aver capito
vabbè dai tutto sommato è capibile non è
proprio scritto in marziano aramaico
vabbè comunque andiamo avanti siamo
fantastico siamo partiti lingue ho
girato al parà illuminare stato guarda
dipende o il martedì o mercoledì
dipendenze sono libero comunque ti
faccio sapere
direi che possiamo iniziare raga allora
destino questa è la strada per il
destino devo riuscire bene un cazzo tra
l'altro come non c'è una luce
maledizione allora va bene noi
proseguiamo lo stesso vi giuro raga non
vedo una ceppa c'è qualcosa lì a te ok
dove cazzo sono caduto
vabbè ok fantastico cos'è sta roba per
piegare item fantastico se chiave ho
preso una chiave chiave ed è
amministrato fantastico a becco i tuoni
vedo già qualcosa di più un ora che
veramente non vedo un cazzo ma si fa
guardando dragon ball da piccole
imparato che quando non sai la strada
devi seguire il tuo destino quindi direi
di andare dove c'è scritto destino
andiamo a sinistra perfetto i tuoni sono
fantastici
ebbene c'è una che cos'è sta roba è la
stanza del generatore fantastico volta
una valvola paralizzarono generatore ok
c'è una torcia fantastico
ok ragazzi a un'altra chiave perfetto
mini chiave fu già fa vj cerri quasi
vabbè te lo passo per stavolta fugge ad
esse lugar va bene io direi di prendere
la luce per ok ci siamo ragazzi vedo ci
posso vedere almeno questo già che non
capisco un cazzo valvola riserva è stata
sala da admin ok non c'ho capito un
cazzo ma non imparano a porta trunk ad
ok non si entra
e devo andare nella stanza del
dell'admin da quanto ho capito se
opposto inizia a piacermi veramente
maledetta luce che cazzo
va bene c'è non mi piace sto posto non
mi piace per niente aprire non si apre
un cazzo
devo andare dove vado ci sono i sessi
che mi rassicurano quindi sono a posto è
ok
che cazzo è successo
stai guardando a quella l'allarme
antincendio mi pare dar fuoco a sta roba
ok devo dar fuoco a sta roba perché è
perché e le uscite di sicurezza ok ok
cos'è questo chiave chiave mestre sto
trovando tutte le chiavi del mondo anche
se non so che cazzo mi servono perché
non ci sono porte da aprire però in
compenso lui mi fa vedere che c'è
l'allarme antincendio giustamente e
vabbè io direi di andare avanti
sono entrato qui dentro non ancora ok ci
manca un'altra chiave perfetto
qualcos'altro ma che cazzo mi servono
stesse chiavi me lo dovete spiegare
comunque va bene ok questo era ok
perfetto
la stanza della cecchetto era sporca
[ __ ] che cagà ok è un'altra chiave
andiamo via
sul successo bene ok chiave do almo non
leggo perché tanto non si capisce un
cazzo
raga è che non cos'è sta roba la valvola
di riserva l'ho trovata
l'ho trovata è successo non so che cosa
ma l'ho trovata va bene non ho capito
che sinceramente chi mi è passato
davanti ma è passato in una maniera che
ebbi giuro non me l'aspettavo ok ragazzi
sono ci siamo con la valvola giriamo la
valvola perfetto e adesso lo girarle
tutto cosa devo devo sileo accese tutte
quante che cazzo mi servono
sinceramente non ho ben capito che cosa
ok
devo a perfetto gli ospiti devo
attivarli probabilmente con un certo
ordine
qua c'è il giallo rosso verde blu che
prefetto vai giallo rosso verde blu
vai che ci siamo ma vj l'elettrotecnico
devo riuscire ad andare via dal suo
posto di specchi ok è saltato qualcosa
devo riuscire ad andarmene via c e che
cazzo
va bene me ne vado prima di far danni
non ho capito bene che cosa mi è servito
fare sta roba ma io me ne vado
ok sia aperta una porta il cast successo
si mi si è aperta una porta fantastico è
già qualcosa devo andare dall'altra
parte che i binari lì attraverso
tranquillamente speriamo non passa un
treno adesso perché ci sono sì
sottofondi di merda perché perché
maledizione per che cosa porta in terra
da hank ore va beh sì giacché non
capisco un cazzo
almeno fa mi provare a leggere neanche
quel piccolo aiuto ok don matteo che
accontenterà tutti
aiuto aiuto che cazzo devo entrare
perché no è tutto chiuso come cazzo si
va via da questo posto di merda di qua
apri chiudi qualsiasi cosa
cos'è sta roba un caccia rito che
perfetto devo devo entrare prima che
cosa fare mi scopre che cazzo bene sono
ha bloccato raga è partito anche un
contatore non so che cazzo ed a roma in
atto ii ci sono i minuti c'era qualcuno
l'ho visto ho visto io tutto sbagliato
africa
ecco
ok
cos'è quella roba lì ma spiegate veloce
dio mio è inquietante da morire sta roba
veramente non so neanche spiegarlo cioè
questo è veramente pesante perché porca
[ __ ] mi consigliate sti giochi perché
che cazzo vabbè io direi di riprovare di
nuovo perché
un postatori iniziare proprio da capo
fantastico bene raga direi di tagliare
finché non arrivò di nuovo a quel punto
ok ragazzi sono di nuovo devo dove ho
capito bene che cosa devo fare
sinceramente devo tipo aprire la porta
ma non so come si apre c'era ok questo
tipo c'era un cacciavite cacciavite dove
l'avevo preso mi ricordo più a jal in
fondo perfetto bene è fantastico ok devo
soltanto riuscire a capire che il cazzo
dove facce ok celentano la maledizione
costi affari di matthew lee la forza
porca [ __ ] chiude non si chiude merda
beh c'è una lampadina fantastico c'è
un'altra 4 cucchiai si giochi visto
gioco si trovano chiavi a caso è bene
devo cos'è sta roba qui il generatore
che cazzo non si capisce un cazzo prima
che esploda tutto quello l'ho capito ma
non ho capito tutto il resto che era
quello importante bene ciò sta roba che
non so che cosa mi serve
penso che io debba mettere tipo qua
credo si infatti vai manca il codice
però non lo so
il cazzo metto bene raga direi di andare
a svitare il come si chiama l'affare la
porca [ __ ] non mi viene il nome
l'allarme antincendio ok la luce mi fa
sempre cagherà adosso devo svitare sto a
fare credo perché qualcosa serve o che
hanno una lampadina fantastico e che
cosa mi ha 23 31 perfetto il codice
della porta
2331 veit devo riuscire a non farmi
stuprare prima di arrivare lì ci
riuscirò mai penso di no ma ok posto
facciamo posso fare 6 2 3 3 1 2 3 3 1
vai così vai cos'è ce l'ho fatta ok c'è
qualcosa che un'altra chiave tanto per
cambiare trovo chiavi bene non c'è più
altre chiama anche cazzo che le facili
tutte ste chiavi merda
va beh qualcosa private
porca [ __ ] via dove si s dove è
riuscita a non sia maledizione degli
aprirti subito aprite qualcosa qualcosa
che si apra dove cazzo vado mio zio si
sia aperta cos'è sta roba
apri ap qualsiasi cosa
si vabbè che cosa lo fa ad aprirlo con
quattro mini chiavi 13 ma edizione due
siti è stata la luce merda non erano
dove si trovano altra mini chiave rega
devo trovare la mini chiave prima di
aprire su marchi e cazzo sta merda non
me l'aspetto maledizione non me
l'aspetto
devo riuscire a trovare un'altra [ __ ]
mini chiave questa forse se ci sono ne
ho quattro [ __ ] 14
devo capire questa roba che non ho
capito cosa serve c'è un'altra chiave sì
tanto chi se ne fotte
devo aprire qualcos'altro tanto ormai
non ci capisco più un cazzo
c'e nessuno ok bene bene vai non sia
un'edizione devo riuscire a trovare ok
devo riuscire a trovare la porta che si
apre e questo penso ok che cazzo è il
paradiso
un giorno devo che cazzo è successo sono
entrato da poiché ho finito c'è questa
la fine
è finito così mi prendete per il culo ma
che cazzo di senza vera sto gioco io non
ho capito che cosa ho appena giocato
non so perché voi mi consigliate ste
robe non lo voglio sapere
mi sono preso degli infarti a caso senza
motivo comunque ora che sa voglio farvi
sapere che questo era soltanto diciamo
il primo livello di pesa delo perché non
è finito qui purtroppo per me quindi
raga dai mi piace che metterete a questo
video vedrò se continuare o no perché se
ovviamente ci sono tanti mi piace devo
dedurre che devo ancora prendermi molti
infarti con questa roba è quindi lei
caso lo continuerò comunque se vi dove
piaciuto lasciato argomento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovato
nella descrizione se non siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo in
un prossimo video bene ragazzi